- Oh my god.
Holy (beep).
(instrumental)
- Korean face masks,
my girlfriend loves these,
and honestly they just
look terrifying on her.
- I know nothing about Korean skin care.
- I've seen some K-pop stars
and they look very smooth?
- Apparently, this stuff
is like miraculous.
- Snail spit is a thing.
- I'm ready to look flawless.
- [Steven] Alright, butterfly eyes.
Perfect for my problem area.
- Okay, so brightens me up.
I'm ready to be brightened.
- Get a first, first a nice whiff.
- Slimy in there. Eww.
(instrumental)
- Just keeping these up.
Hideaway like a little ghost.
- Oh, I feel like a luby superhero.
- Yeah, this just feels
like there's a used condom
on my face, not that I would know
what that feels like.
- I feel my skin is like drinking water.
- I'm hoping this makes my skin tighter.
- It's just, like, not
the best looking thing,
but it feels great.
Yes!
I'm going to be a tiger.
- You know, I don't get pampered enough,
so this is perfect.
- This is horrifying.
This is horrifying.
- The fuck, is this a fruit roll up?
- Beauty, here I come!
- Oh, It feel so good!
- Oh, it's so cold!
- Wait, let me see myself.
Okay I've got to take this off.
(laughs)
- Jesus Christ.
- My roommate will wear these
and she'll come out of her
room and she'll be like,
hi, how's it going,
and I'll be like, oh my god.
- You remember that movie,
The Mask, with Jim Carey?
That was based off the horrifying
true story of this mask.
- If this were just my dating profile,
just me out in the woods, sort of like,
- I'm wearing the skin
of somebody I murdered.
- I actually want to look
like this all the time.
Now I understand what
furries are all about.
Milky Piggy Bubble Mask,
already a big fan of the milky piggy.
- I don't know how I
feel about that texture.
- Aw man, I'm all
captain crunchy and shit.
- Oh, it's itchy!
- Okay, I see you, Steven.
- Who's a milky piggy?
Me, me, me.
- Is it moving?
Oh my god, it's pop rocking on my face.
- God, it's all puffy.
It's all puffing up.
- This is so grotesque.
- Oh my god, I do look like Squidward.
- It's burning a little
more than the other ones.
- It's like tighter boning my face.
Make it stop!
- There are tiny little elves
just blowing on my face,
just like-
- I quit.
- You know, I had a great time with this.
(sighs)
- That was fun.
- My skin does feel less oily.
- No, it feels really good.
Steven probably pooped his pants
and couldn't handle it,
but that's okay.
- I'm going to go buy some of
these and join my girlfriend.
- I don't want to see that
in the mirror ever again.
Out behind a corner you see me jump out,
like I'm here, too.
That'd be a happy sight for anyone.